We Begin this hour with our new series
Never Too Late setting out to prove that
it's never too late for anyone to try
something new that's what we say around
here CBS mornings viewers at home you
guys know that Gail loves to sing right
she sings on off camera all the time she
does take a look
all I wanna do is have some fun I love
that song
you're with me all the while the popular
songs
music save your mortal soul and can you
tell me how to dance real slow
I really do I really decided it wasn't
too late
professional voice lessons right I
decided that I thought I like Oprah in
the car though she's just like you know
she she was not appreciative of my time
but that's one of the great things about
this job it allows you to do stuff like
this I got to get into the studio with a
legendary producer and Legend is a word
a Superstar singer Superstar is a word
to record a song but before that I went
to the home of celebrity vocal coach
Stevie Mackey for some very much needed
lessons
[Applause]
deadline
there we go
[Music]
oh you have your work put up for you
today
it is Queen Gail Stevie Mackey has sung
with the best of the best my first real
background singing gig I sank background
for Whitney Houston in a Christmas album
and I couldn't believe it was happening
now the vocal coach the superstars like
Jennifer Lopez Selena Gomez and Kelly
Rowland is a singing sensation in his
own right
of time
before we got to my lesson we talked
about our mutual obsession with songs
and I want you to know I'm under No
Illusion today because I really know
that I cannot sing so but I I still love
music I think there's a song for every
situation do you I do and I think
music's the most powerful thing in the
world probably why besides prayer uh
besides prayer but I think music is able
to change hearts and that makes it the
most powerful thing all right you say
you like a challenge let's go will we
still be friends when this is over
Absolutely I'll be very honest with you
and I think you appreciate it and I
appreciate I appreciate honesty I really
do good but you can be kind I'm kind
first okay let's go right now Gail we
are going to do a warm-up and I'm gonna
find out your range okay so but it'll be
a fun do I have a range everyone has a
range okay but some some ranges are just
but we'll see what you got oh yeah
yeah do that
oh yeah right on
right on fish all right that's a good
start really that's important oh yeah
yeah oh yeah
loud as you can give it to me oh yeah
yes okay yeah it's a little rough right
there it's a little rough right there
yeah
now imagine going up real high I want to
see something
oh yeah
oh yeah
yeah I think the high and the low is
fine but the middle area is a little
okay there's some spider webs in there
okay it can improve it can
I see I see some light at the end of
this tunnel do you I do bring it down a
little bit no matter how far don't worry
baby Just Call My Name I'll be there in
a hurry you don't have to worry okay
baby there okay okay all right all right
yeah we're runaway train we are getting
there all right okay I actually loved
how that started do you think I could
sing Natural Woman is that too much oh
don't give me started Rita Let's see we
have a couple minutes let's see let's
see we got here
[Music]
I used to feel
so uninspired okay
now it was time to head to the studio
where we asked for help from some very
familiar faces in the industry David
Foster 16-time Grammy award-winning
producer and songwriter and Catherine
McPhee American Idol runner-up turned
chart-topping TV star and oh yeah the
pair also happens to be husband and wife
[Music]
music brought you guys together well I
was a little contestant on American Idol
yeah he was a guest Mentor I know how
much but I know you're brutally honest
and I know well no not today I won't be
okay no no
um I have a question for you dude ask
you a question yes yes is it frustrating
for you
as much as you love music to not have
the voice that you would want to have
yes yes it must be yes it is because but
you know what David it's not like I'm
trying to be on a stage no no or to have
people ah Gail I love you it's not that
you know Stevie knows this too as an
amazing singer himself and an amazing
teacher my mom's a voice teacher as well
and so she has all different types of
people coming who just like want to sing
for fun and you can sing for fun that's
what I wanted you can do better you can
now Dave I want you to try a little bit
of Natural Woman a flat before the day I
met you
life was so unkind
you're the key to my peace of mind let's
do that again in three part okay got it
you make me make me feel like I'm
natural
woman I think that's our way
come on that's the winner that's the
winner after a few more takes
some strings
and a little make that a lot of fine
tuning here's our finished product
foreign
[Music]
Lord it made me feel so tired
before the day I met you
life was so unkind but you're the key to
my peace of mind cause you may
You Make Me Feel You
make me feel like a natural woman
[Laughter]
oh man great show my people call your
people to work out of jail
that's great thank you thank you
Thomas hilarious I have to thank my
people Gisella Alicia Alice and Katie
that was so much fun to watch great job
that was awesome Tony hi Tony decopal I
want to see them I don't have picture I
only have audio here in my basement
playroom and I I do I kid you not what I
was thinking as I was listening to your
voices is that Carol King or Gail King
because you're oh okay yeah I feel like
I feel like Simon Cowell here on
America's Got Talent your voice went
from here to here and I I will now say I
will declare it to quote Step Brothers
uh you have the voice of an Angel it's a
confidential at this point it's true and
Gail that's funny what he said about
Carol King because Tony did you know
Carol King actually wrote that song yeah
Carole King wrote that song oh you
didn't know Carole King wrote that song
I love that you tackled Natural Woman is
probably one of the most difficult songs
ever recorded Aretha Franklin and you
know Carol also who is probably spinning
in her room right now no no
I would pick something like you know on
top of old spaghetti or something but
you went for like you went for yeah you
know it's just that I so love that song
I love the words to it I love how Aretha
sang it you did it I do think it's
difficult but I think I I cannot thank
Catherine enough and David enough and
Stevie enough because that was a
Saturday they took a big chunk of their
Saturday their days off to come and play
with us and I'm forever grateful and
Vincent Ruiz who is a genius when it
comes to editing I love because Nate
said oh that was a phony shot with the
dog the dog actually did that yeah you
went from the dog
that's what was so funny about it all
right Tony so what do you have coming up
for us yeah Tony you're up tomorrow I'm
up tomorrow so in Gail's case she always
had the confidence to be a singer now
she's got the pitch and the resonance in
my case when it came to dancing I never
had the confidence not from middle
school on up uh so we hired a fantastic
choreographer and Dancer named Jessica
Castro who did her absolute best over
many many hours to get me onto the Dance
Floor nothing special just feeling
comfortable enough to cut a rug at a
wedding at a bar and have a good time
and I think by the end uh much like
yourself Gail I went from here to here
but we'll have to you'll have to
evaluate the tables will be turned
tomorrow no I can't wait I know we're so
bummed Tony has a little case of the
Rona but Tony you're fine we keep
hearing you're sounding look good man
because we're so bummed you're not here
in the studio but you're okay I was so
upset to miss it but I do feel great uh
and I'll be uh back tomorrow to
introduce my journey through Rhythm and
dance